when was the first time you saw the film
in its entirety with a large audience
and what was your reaction to their
react yeah well I saw it early early on
in a cut and it gave Todd some notes and
and then I don't think I saw it for like
another two months well Todd took those
notes and all the rest of the notes from
all the times and just really fine-tuned
the movie and it was a screening for
Warner Brothers for like their worldwide
distribution I thought it was just a
screening he was gonna have for a couple
people Todd's like you want to see the
movie it's basically in its cut where I
think it's nearly nearly final cut if
not close and as I guess sure and then
when I went I went oh I didn't realize
it was like gonna be 400 people here and
like not a test audience but like
actually the Warner Brothers
distribution arm of like worldwide and I
was blown away I literally I when the
movie ended I went it's frickin
masterpiece like and I wasn't just me
like because I was a part of it in fact
I'm way harder on the movies I'm a part
of and can rarely separate myself in a
real objective way to like watch it and
get lost in it but I remember when he
does the stuff at the end and he's on
top of the police car and it just felt
so powerful and so operatic that I just
remember thinking god this is even
better than I thought it would be and I
thought it would be pretty good and I
think helping you know the audience
there and just really sensing the size
and the scope of the movie on that
screen and Warner Brothers said we work
so it's a really big screen so seeing
the power of that having just witnessed
it now on it editing monitors that were
quite small yeah I was I was actually
quite blown away and then I thought oh
jeez this thing could really be a hit
yeah were there reactions or not not
amazingly here's the thing the funny
part about that was I was like because I
turn to my wife who's there and I said
like halfway through or something like
is this working for you because unlike a
comedy where people are laughing you
really know like hangover I remember the
first time I start with an audience
you were like oh boy this thing is
actually could be a really big hit
because it was like raucous and you
could feel it in here
anyway I turned to her and I said is
this working for you she goes it's
amazing like loving I go alright good
because I'm feeling the same way you
could sense the audience you could feel
their engagement you know you know you
know when audiences are fidgeting
there's a lot of like things signs that
you can tell with an audience to see if
it's working particularly a movie that
you're not you're not looking for laughs
but you're looking for engagement
sometimes that's hard to see but when
the movie ended I was expecting because
also it was like Warner Brothers and
their distribution arm for there to be
just like spontaneous clapping like I
was even expecting like a standing
ovation and like there was none of that
and I went I was so weird and Todd goes
no no trust me I have watch this with
just smaller audiences too they never
they're usually just sit stuff and I
went right right right because then I
remember it took like a day in which I
could finally digest it and then started
talking to people I recognized that they
the common experience of the movie is
that not one of like clapping but one of
like like digesting what they've just
seen and being a little bit just frozen
and then a day later going oh my god
that movie was this or this movie really
worked for me and so we had like whole
reception afterwards with like
distribution people and from those
people throughout the pitman throughout
that afterwards people would go oh my
god this movie's amazing so I went oh
good it was working for everyone but it
didn't have that natural thing that
happens sometimes at the end of a movie
where there's like a sense of like
applause you know and all that kind of
stuff so it was an interesting
experience in that regard but clearly it
worked because you know they were really
high on it and all that stuff so yeah
great yeah you're right it does take
what I mean I was still thinking about
it I think two nights later yeah letters
friends and emails and stuff they're
there they say that they go yeah I just
needed a day or two but now I recognize
like it and then and this is you don't
get to a billion dollars without people
going more than once generally speaking
there have been a lot of people I know
you know and people I don't think
generally go see movies more than
ones who have gone more than once - then
have it - like now know what the
experience was because I think it was it
was a different I think it was different
than anyone expected
certainly the trailer gave clues as to
the tone of the movie but I think I
think one of the surprises was what the
movie wasn't for the fans and what's
nice is that that was cool they were
cool with that you know sometimes I mean
I see even now with just this new Star
Wars movie fans are just they have such
a relationship with these movies and and
you know and so the people that were mad
at Ron Johnson are happy of what they
made changes in the new version but the
people that love the Rian Johnson
version are mad about what JJ Abrams is
like you can't please everyone so you
but you recognize it like they have a
relationship with these characters in
these movies so you have to be aware
that they're part of the experience and
so I think even if you want to stand
outside of that you still have to have
some interest into what their
experiences with the movie and I think I
think what's interesting is that the I
think a lot of the fans and in that
universe were happy that it was so
different and different unexpected
darker like you know they weren't as
upset over the things that we thought
they might be there's not enough action
it's not a comic book movie it doesn't
have this it doesn't have that all the
things that may be in the back of your
head you're going will the movie feel
too small well the movie not you know
service this sort of crowd that is it
has an expectation of what a joker movie
would be where all the things that I
think people really embraced and I think
it's great for the movie industry at
large that a movie that you know isn't
all those things can still make a
billion dollars on a lighter note I
think there's like an old Saturday Night
Live skit with William Shatner or he
like addresses yes crowd of track yes
people it was a TV show you know but
that it encompasses this it meant so
much that's right that's right
we have relationships with movies are so
powerful and they're so good at moving
you emotionally and and when they're
done well they really you know you have
a connection with them and so and then
they become even more powerful as time
goes by and you know and so listen I I
think you you have to make movies aware
of your audience but not for your
audience right but I think you have to
also be aware of that day that they
exist in there they're there they're
part of the experience you know but you
hope that you don't necessarily cater
everything to them because as a
filmmaker your job is to tell this story
and and hope that if you tell it with
you know a very specific point of view
that it will connect with audiences at
large were you aware that so many people
that aren't necessarily into the comic
book genre would love the film I was my
hope because I came at it from a person
who is not a huge comic book fan so my
hope is like well my parents would see
it like they wouldn't necessarily go see
you know ant-man but you know because
they would think of as a comic book
movie but hopefully they would go see
this and enjoy it because they would it
wouldn't simply exist under that heading
you know and with exists on its own so
that was the hope and obviously you know
we can see they like what it is I
thought as we're making it for sure that
he goes we were making it I was saying I
was for sure going that audience it
doesn't like car movies will like this
but now we got to make sure we're not
you know that the audience that loves
them won't feel like what the hell is
this but but I sort of knew that what we
were making would service both because I
thought well first we're making a good
movie but I think in a weird way we're
making a movie that's very much like a
comic book movie in the truest sense in
the way that like kids when they're 10
years old would have this like very
personal experience with the actual
comic book right where it's just images
on a piece of paper with writing that
you
have to then bring your own imagination
into the sort of deep emotion of it and
just like a novel would and I thought
like oh you know but it's a picture
novel right so literally it's like if we
can create these engaging images and we
and that in a way we were gonna create
something that maybe a very much a comic
book movie or certainly a movie that
feels like a graphic novel so you know
and and giving credit to your I think
with sociology teacher you mentioned
that he said ya know these are a product
of our decade or been butchering what he
said no I wouldn't I wasn't a film major
in college I was an economics major but
I I got into film late and then started
taking some classes because it was an
economics major I was always interested
in sort of cause and effect of things so
he was a sociology and a film professor
he did both and it was it was a
basically that the construct of the
class was every movie can be seen as a
product of the time in which it was made
Ryan week in that class we literally
looked at the way three amigos
represented like iran-contra and like
that and it was like and so I'm always
fascinated literally to this day I've
never forgotten like what Richard
Slotkin who was the name of the
professor it said because now I always
look at the like even a year in movies
right and I look at them and I see what
are the trends here right and like what
are the trends that that we see in what
movies are being made you know I
remember I can't remember if it was like
the year of the revenant it was like
also the year of that all is lost movie
with Robert Redford and there was like
another movie and they're all movies
about like people lonely Pete like alone
trying to survive under great odds like
and it was like well what is that saying
about our society right now or certainly
like what does it say that over the last
11 years right like Ironman one came out
in 2008 let's say right right and that
kind of like restarted the whole Marvel
franchise right and
and this is just a theory but like under
the same principle that this professor
said is the GFC happened right we now
have like watched an entire nation of
like and world of bankers and like
irresponsible practices dismantle the
economy and nobody got taken a task
there was no justice at large there was
no justice nobody went into prison right
fines all this stuff and nobody
literally got pulled off in handcuffs
outside of maybe one guy and and I go so
we live in a world that has an injustice
well what better place to show to like
have superhero movies become the most
you know popular genre of movie for the
last ten years because we live in a
world in which I think often we don't
see justice so what you saw where do you
find justice you find justice in
superhero movies but you're not getting
justice from politicians you're not
getting justice from from you know
judges and lawyers you're getting
justice from like a literal superhero
they're the only ones who can give us
justice which isn't even realistic
because they don't exist
so we've created this thing in which we
now want to go see justice in movies
because we're not getting in in real
life so then there are microcosms that
every year in moviemaking so what is
what our movies trying to tell us about
society and how are they reflecting
society and I've always believed every
movie is a reflection of the director's
personal point of view and they're a
reflection of the society at large
because I think we all make movies in
the context of when they're made you
know and so so I'm always fascinated by
that for sure
you